Communist Party Congress
we gathered outside the
consulate
chat
uh
is played some banners
it was a peaceful
protest unit
a uh sorry it was a peaceful protest you
need a master
man
attempted to take down our displays
and started to act a good safely toward
us
he was soon joined by other masked men
I was in the midst of things outside the
gates of the consulate
trying to stop The Mastermind from
taking away our displays
I then found myself being drafted into
the
grounds of the consulates
I held onto the gate
where I was kicked and punched
I could not hold on for long
and
was eventually pulled into the grounds
of the consulate
it will stand my hair was pulled
and I felt
I I felt punches and kicks from
sofa sofa men
other protectors were
trying to get me out of this situation
but to know
about
the attack only stopped when a man who
turned it out to be a uniformed officer
from the greater Manchester police
pulled me outside the gate
let me say again so it is clear I was
dropped into the consulate
I did not attempt to enter the consulate
for February
I'm shocked and hurt by this
on perfect attack
I'm shocked because I never thought
something like this could happen in the
UK
six masked men were involved
I now have
bruises on my eyes
my head my neck and over over my back
I feel I may be
silenced
by the powers that be
I fear for the safety of my family
but I must take this opportunity to send
the greater Manchester police they are
taking this attack very seriously and
I'm committed to helping with the
investigation